Okay.
I'm going to talk about Napoleon.
I today,
it was about,
or maybe 10 years ago at
during the French Open,
before the French Open,
you know,
the tennis tournament that
a band pay puts on every,
uh,
every late spring.
Uh,
they took one of the American players,
female player,
uh,
on a quick limousine,
a tour of,
of Paris of a full day.
And at the end,
they,
if someone asked her a French,
uh,
host Asco,
what did you like best
about the tour of Paris?
And she said,
uh,
the best thing was the tomb
of the little dead dude.
I couldn't make that up.
Uh,
uh,
and Napoleon continues
to fascinate though,
not necessarily me.
Um,
either the straight,
the coverage in the,
in what you're reading is,
is straight forward.
So today I'm gonna talk
about a couple of themes.
Uh,
first of all,
uh,
what was Corsican,
what remained Corsican about Napoleon,
uh,
and then maybe discuss a,
a question raised by David Bell of late,
um,
was the revolutionary period
in particularly Napoleon,
the,
the first total war,
uh,
in the sense that 20th century folks,
and at least you were
born in the 20th century.
I have come to,
uh,
to understand and then the end,
just don't ramble a bit,
but just talk about what the
most important contributions of,
uh,
of Napoleon.
Um,
uh,
what,
what the,
what they were,
um,
somebody counted up,
not me.
Uh,
that,
uh,
by 1980,
there had been two,
at least 220,000 books and articles
published on Napoleon in a variety of
languages.
Um,
three recent books,
which just if you,
if your Napoleon buffs or simply want to,
uh,
read about him,
that are,
that are quite good in English are,
uh,
my old friend Steven England's book,
Napoleon,
uh,
a political history,
which came out three or four years ago
and was recently translated into French
Philip Dwyer's a,
a book on Napoleon,
uh,
up to 1799.
I filliped wire,
you know,
hates Napoleon.
Uh,
but it's a pretty interesting,
um,
uh,
look at,
the early career.
Uh,
and finally,
uh,
I suppose mostly most controversially,
a David Bell's a book,
the first total war,
uh,
which I'll discuss some
of the themes in a while.
It was only about six or seven years ago.
I remember this,
that they discovered in Lithuania.
Um,
a whole,
uh,
a whole bunch of,
of,
of bones of dead bones
with bones are dead.
I guess I'm going,
if they've been there for
200 years or whatever,
but of of um,
uh,
not a grave site because they
were never probably buried,
but,
uh,
a place where expired in the snows of,
of 18,
12,
uh,
a good number of soldiers of
Napoleon has gone down on me.
The big,
uh,
the big army.
Um,
and so,
I mean,
ninth,
18,
12,
still,
uh,
I still,
goes on.
Um,
there was,
uh,
there was a book also interesting book
if you're looking for paper topics,
uh,
that I,
I sometimes assign in the French course
called diary of a Napoleonic foot
soldier a.
And by the time of 18,
12,
uh,
the majority of the going on me were,
were really people who'd
been conscripted or,
uh,
impounded,
if you will,
uh,
in various allied states.
But it's a quite interesting account of,
of what it was like,
uh,
in Napoleon's armies as he invaded
a further and further into,
um,
uh,
eastern,
Europe.
Um,
by the way,
among the,
uh,
you know,
I just did a subject
search on Napoleon once.
I don't know why,
but,
uh,
um,
of the 220,000 books,
you probably will want to,
um,
uh,
not read the tantalizing a 1894
classic Napoleon and the fair sex,
uh,
or Napoleon and his women friends,
which was from 1927.
Napoleon in love.
I mean,
there are lots of those 1959,
and the Polian seen my Canadian,
uh,
published in,
in,
in 19,
uh,
30,
seven.
So,
um,
and I,
I talk a lot about Napoleon's life in,
in,
in the textbook.
But let's,
let's look at the theme of,
uh,
of Napoleon and Corsica.
I once took a whole flock
of Yale Alumni to see,
uh,
Napoleon's house in [inaudible]
where he was born on the 15th of,
um,
uh,
of,
of August.
Um,
he,
he wrote in a letter to the course that
can patriot with whom he subsequently
broke,
uh,
poly.
Uh,
he wrote on the 12th of June,
1789,
I was born when the French
were vomited upon our coasts.
That is the coast of Corsica drowning,
the thrown of liberty
and torrents of blood.
Such was the odious spectacle
that first met my eyes.
The cries of the dying,
the groans of the oppressed tiers
of despair surrounded my cradle,
uh,
at my birth.
Uh,
of course it guys,
I'm sure you know,
it is an island,
a big island,
a,
it's a north of Sardinia
a which belongs to Italy.
Um,
he at first gloried in
his Corsican origins,
I hating the French who
had conquered his island.
Of course,
the French revolution would change all
that and that's why it's a good idea to
look at him as you look at
Robespierre and others and see what,
uh,
what difference a,
there were French revolution,
uh,
made between a 1785 near I'm
drawing on Dwyer and 1795.
That is between the age of 16 and 26.
He wrote a number of,
of notes and sketches and short stories,
uh,
that reveal much about
his attachment to Corsica,
but also the,
that suggests the dramatic nature of the
change as he embraces the revolution.
Uh,
and France now he spoke Corsican,
uh,
and,
and not French,
so French with a second language.
And,
and Corsican is a,
is,
uh,
you know,
it's a language,
it's a Patois,
uh,
that is closer,
more closely tied to a
Patois or dialect of,
of northern,
uh,
northern Italy.
In fact,
when you drive around in Corsica,
most of the radio
stations that you can get,
or,
you know,
our,
our Italian,
uh,
and,
and not,
not French.
Um,
he learned French and he made
errors even at the end of his life.
He made errors.
And French,
though he wrote,
wrote French,
uh,
very well.
Um,
so he was bilingual,
but he never lost his accent.
And,
uh,
one of the things about northern French,
people in particular is that
they're less likely to forgive.
It's southern accents.
And,
and,
and of course,
one of the stereotypes of course,
Atkins,
is they all become policemen in Paris.
Uh,
and as many of them have,
I have eyes at the end of the law,
uh,
of their name,
and they have a very strong,
uh,
southern French accent that it,
that is,
it's not really a Toulouse accent,
uh,
or,
you know,
are part of a,
uh,
France.
And our Desha accident where you can
always tell if those of you know French,
and again,
if you don't have fringe,
doesn't make a slight bit of difference,
but somebody who says the Coteau Vanga
instead of cuts or VA or cast sang
instead of the,
uh,
the great a human rights
advocate to a knee,
a Casa,
the Sangha or a Vang on which want to,
via the Vanga,
you know,
a glass of wine instead of vap.
Uh,
so of course,
I mean,
it's a famous story about
Napoleon and when he,
when he goes off to military school as
a very young boy that they made fun of
his accent.
Uh,
and one more about that,
um,
uh,
in a while.
But anyway,
um,
at the beginning he,
he hated the French and,
um,
uh,
espouse to the fact that he was,
a course it can,
he felt culturally marginal.
Um,
and this was compounded by his personal
loneliness when he was assigned to
Veloce,
uh,
which could make anyone
sort are mildly depressed.
Um,
uh,
I lost on the Rhone River.
He contemplated suicide quite seriously.
Uh,
he,
uh,
spent a lot of time in sort of reading
and just sort of hanging out by himself
and,
and the,
through much of a zoo early days,
uh,
lacked.
Um,
he,
he lacked,
uh,
um,
he liked,
he liked friends.
Um,
in 1768 Corsica,
which had been part of,
of the Republic of,
of,
of that is the port city of Genoa,
just,
you know,
foss,
I mean,
really across the,
the sea gave up course it could
to France or really sold it.
The French state actively work to try to
create a loyal horse that can nobility
and thus the family of Napoleon,
the bone of paths.
And p o n a p a r t,
e s,
uh,
who had a you that he
subsequently took out of his name,
uh,
in the first four letters,
were ennobled in 1771,
uh,
by the French.
But I mean,
all nobles aren't rich as you know.
And so he was sort of what you'd call
in French and Oba Ho sort of rapport,
a noble a four of Carlo that his,
his,
his dad,
uh,
Bonaparte's eight children received
scholarships to study in France,
including Napoleon who,
uh,
was sent to a place called blue hen.
It doesn't matter.
Uh,
in the north of France,
50 of the hundred and 10 students in
the school were called royal scholars.
So here again,
here's kind of a comparison to,
uh,
to,
that case of downward mobility.
Uh,
Hovis piano,
uh,
who was also a scholarship,
a guy.
And there was nothing wrong with that
at all except that there were a lot of
fancy noble offspring there too,
who had another reason to knock two mock,
uh,
an Napoleon.
Um,
and so,
um,
he wrote in [inaudible] where he was when
he was posted to violence again on the
Rhone River about an hour now by car,
south of,
of,
of uh,
legal.
Uh,
he wrote that life was a burden,
uh,
because there was no pleasure is nothing
but pain is a burden because the men
and women with whom I live and
probably will always have to live,
have customs that are as far from mine
as the light of the moon is different
from the light of the sun.
But yeah,
there was yet there was
French influence in his life.
He read the fill the sof,
he had whoso Voltaire,
Montesquieu and in 1791,
again,
I don't want to push this comparison
because he was different in many ways then
what was the piano?
But like Robespierre he had,
ed enters an essay contest
sponsored by an academy,
an academy in this case,
the Academy of,
of Lille.
Um,
but his writings,
um,
mostly reflect an
obsession with his origins.
I haven't read a lot
of his early writings,
but Philip Dwyer,
uh,
has,
um,
one of his colleagues in
school drew a cartoon of,
of Napoleon rushing to
Corsica to aid the course.
It can revel rebel Paoli and he must've
discussed this with his friends.
And he also battled with those as he
saw us as rivals a long time ago in the
1920s,
I guess it was,
uh,
the producer about gos produced
this three and a half hour film,
which actually is extremely boring,
called Napoleon wall,
uh,
with without sound.
But the most famous scene in it arguably
is a snowball fight where Napoleon,
uh,
it takes a snowball fight to
a more serious dimension and,
and tries out tactics and,
and uh,
and all of this,
but in a way,
you know,
is fighting for his,
his,
you know,
his independence and the status as a,
as,
uh,
non-French Corsican but who been
washed up on the shores of France by,
uh,
by a fortune,
a good or a bad.
And at that point,
he wasn't really too sure,
uh,
what it was.
He began to write a history of Corsica,
uh,
less than a hundred pages,
which he thought took seriously enough
to begin to revise in the early 1790s
after the French revolution.
And in it,
according to Phil Dwyer,
he portrays Corsicans as courageous,
even heroic,
and throwing off the rule of Genoa
and battling the French for over 24
centuries.
He wrote the same scenes,
had been repeated without interruption.
The same assisted tutes,
the same misfortunes,
but also the same courage,
the same resolution,
the same,
uh,
Udacity.
Um,
but you know,
his letters in his writings reveal
the folks that he was writing.
I reading that is the influence of the,
of the philosophic,
uh,
portraying,
you know,
Corsica,
uh,
seeking liberty,
in the shadow of a,
of oppression,
uh,
in opposition to royal authority,
um,
based.
So he links kind of Phyllis
the themes of the philosophic,
uh,
in the fence.
Of course it can,
uh,
of course,
it gets fight for a freedom.
Um,
so even in the 1790s,
if this is true,
interpretation is correct.
Uh,
he did not see his,
uh,
identity is both Corsican in French,
but rather as,
as Corsican.
Uh,
but by 1799,
uh,
when he,
with the help of the Wiley Ab Aca,
yes.
Uh,
comes to power.
I am on the 18th of Bouman.
Uh,
the French identity had overwhelmed,
uh,
his course can identity.
And so the question is,
did he merely catch the nearest way?
Uh,
is it opportunism?
or was it his belief that the French
revolution and the better Fos France,
uh,
offered a liberating possibilities for,
for humanities?
Um,
uh,
in a,
in a short story that he wrote in the
summer of 1789 rather important summer,
uh,
the French were portrayed as,
as tyrants still in his story
called the nouvelle costs or the,
the new,
uh,
Corsica.
Um,
and he,
um,
he used violence and his life
would be one characterized by,
by violence,
uh,
as a way of increasing
sympathy for the course.
It can people also as
a cultural expression,
of course,
it conventions,
you know,
Corsica,
uh,
because of,
I mean,
this isn't just a stereotype,
but,
uh,
because of this,
of flashing knives of
clan and family rivalries,
uh,
there so many crimes in Corsica,
in the 19th century that
the island of Corsica,
which became a depot and they pop them.
Oh,
now it's too,
but one of the departments of
France had to be excluded when,
when,
uh,
somebody was doing a,
study of,
of,
of crime.
Uh,
I,
because there's so many
more crimes in Corsica,
in fact,
still,
uh,
their tradition of flat
flashing lives of knives and,
and,
uh,
you know,
the course getting independence movements,
still places,
bombs sometimes in blows up there,
various independence
movements and blows up,
uh,
Luci small or a,
you know,
a housing development being built for,
uh,
you know,
Parisian or Maasais lawyers
or something like that.
Um,
and it was still are these,
these kinds of,
uh,
resentments.
Um,
so in the beginning he still
identified with Paulie,
but he would break a po
with Paho leak to a poly.
I,
the course can.
Patriot was sort of the scene
as the George Washington of,
of,
uh,
of his,
his,
his island.
Um,
and he was a,
Napoleon was constructing a vision
of what he saw it he could become,
that is to help liberate
Corsica from French rule.
Uh,
how ironic his father Carlo had,
uh,
had in his own view
that is Napoleon's view,
betrayed,
uh,
the course can cause by going over to,
the French.
Um,
and so in a way,
I mean,
you could argue that he's
rebelling against his father.
Um,
uh,
at least in the,
in the early stages.
But the revolution did bring a change.
Obviously,
it transformed the relations
between France and Corsica.
In 1789,
there were four deputies,
uh,
elected,
to the estates general.
And in 1790,
Corsica is recognized as a
Depop tomorrow as a department,
uh,
of course against demanded a royal decree
that would recognize the island as an
integral part of France,
subject to the,
to the laws of France,
um,
and declared that those who had fought
against France ought to be permitted to
return to,
uh,
of their,
homeland.
On the 27th of December.
There were celebrations and all,
of course it can.
Churches,
uh,
and the Polian had a banner hung in,
is not inconsiderable house in a jock CEO,
the family house viva,
Viva [inaudible],
Aviva [inaudible] bull.
Uh,
who had,
so who was,
who had supported the decree long
live the nation long loop polity,
long live in Mujer Hobo.
He's trying to,
he's trying to play it both ways.
He wrote from now on,
we,
that is Corsica and France
have the same interests,
the same concerns.
The sea no longer,
uh,
separates us.
Indeed.
I mean,
that's hardly the case because even today,
of course,
the cup,
there have to be subventions,
uh,
to,
to help,
uh,
keep the cost of food down in Corsica
because of the enormous cost cost of
transporting,
uh,
things that are not produced locally.
I mean,
you can't just live on,
on goat's cheese and
things like that and wine,
a red wine produced in course it goes.
So,
I mean,
the sea,
uh,
does,
matter,
uh,
all of that.
But the revolution helped
Napoleon reconcile some of
the contradictions that had
bothered him a all the way along.
So at this point,
he'd become a French,
a Corsican.
He renounced publishing
some of his letters,
uh,
and began to enter these,
political struggles,
uh,
in the revolution.
Uh,
and he,
indeed,
he was lucky.
I mean,
one of the amazing things about
Napoleon was his luck because it,
uh,
when he might've well been
guillotined as being as Jacoba,
uh,
he was in Corsica or,
in the south of France,
uh,
he was always seemed to
be in the right place.
And this was true in his,
his,
uh,
in his battles as well.
He is tremendously courageous guy.
Uh,
and he,
the guards are always trying to,
his bodyguards,
always trying to get them to,
you know,
move back in the traditional way as,
uh,
an officer or commander,
which he was the commander,
uh,
from the battles.
And,
and he in fact is only
wounded very lightly,
two or three times.
So He's pretty lucky.
They wouldn't,
bodies are falling in,
horses are falling all around him.
I mean,
he,
he remained a,
uh,
an extremely lucky guy.
And this also accounts for his,
uh,
his,
success.
Though even though for
the 18th premier in 1799,
clearly it would be a military person
who is going to put an end to what has
been in delicately called
the war of the chamber pots.
That was the directory.
That is the period of
the Post Thermador uh,
the directory.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
the battle between left and right and,
and,
and the revolution made military men,
uh,
extraordinarily important.
I mean,
there wasn't a king anymore.
Uh,
uh,
and the war,
the chamber pots and the sort of
sleaziness of the period though it was
important in,
in the end,
giving France some sort of parliamentary
experience in a meaningful way meant
that some military person was going to,
uh,
is going to be imposing order in quotes.
I,
and,
uh,
when,
when Ebay cas who had
survived and he have the,
what is the third estate who had also
survived all of this institute of the
revolution.
When he thinks about one general,
one of another military man says,
there's your man,
there's Napoleon who is again,
in the right place,
he's going to do a better coup d'etat,
then the other guy could've done.
And so Napoleon there happened
to be a lucky fellow as well.
In 1793,
uh,
the,
the followers of poly broke with the
convention during the federalist revolts,
which you know about,
and during the expulsion of the,
as you hone down from the convention,
uh,
and then,
the uprisings,
uh,
come in in Leo,
say,
Boldo,
Tutto,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Um,
and those on the outs
with Pau [inaudible],
including Napoleon,
now embraced the Jacoby,
uh,
because,
the course can assembly in a jock CEO,
uh,
by the way,
he's age a Ajaccio eight
j a c c I o Ajaccio,
uh,
turn,
they,
they condemn the Bonaparte's who
had dropped the U in their name,
by the way.
That's in the book as having been born
in the mud of despotism despotism.
Uh,
and he turned,
so Napoleon turned his back
on the independence movement
to which he'd pledged
in the privacy of his room and,
but also in other places
and Brienne of fidelity.
And he now hated poly for whom he,
uh,
blamed for having turned,
so many Corsicans Atkins,
uh,
against,
against France.
Again,
is this the opportunism had he
merely caught the nearest way?
Uh,
but you know,
he had embraced the national identity
of being French and he did take ideas
seriously.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it's our,
it's possible to argue,
I wouldn't believe this,
that,
uh,
the,
the philosophic eventually a one out and
he saw the revolution as a liberating
experience for France
and the construction of,
of,
of a new,
of a new way of imagining the state.
Of course.
Like he turns that into,
uh,
into out and out,
political repression,
his own country,
uh,
and,
the conquest,
the megalomaniac,
a megalomaniac,
what is over there?
Actually with that,
I can't even think of it.
A conquest of all of these other places.
Um,
and when he married,
uh,
you know,
Josephine,
who once somebody said would have drunk
a goal out of the skull of any of her
lovers,
uh,
he made sure that the French,
that the,
that the French spelling,
uh,
on the mirrored certificate,
ah,
was there and not,
and that the,
you are the course that can,
you had been taken out of his name,
um,
on the island of Saint Helena on in the
middle of nowhere where he had a lot of
time to sink.
Um,
he wrote,
I am more shump in Wa.
That was Shampine pinea where Britain,
the town of Brianne was
his military school.
Uh,
you know,
grass upon the champagne
and all these good things.
I am more sharp in Wa then Corsican
because from the age of nine,
I was raised in Brianne.
It would have displeased the French if
I had surrounded myself with Corsicans.
On the contrary,
I want it to be absolutely to be French.
Of all the insults I have had
heaped upon me in so many pamphlets.
Uh,
the one to which I was most
sensitive was that of being Corsica.
Nope.
Napoleon was an inveterate liar,
uh,
particularly when he was trying
to craft was quite clear.
He was already ill.
Uh,
his legacy and much of what he wrote
on the island about is eternal,
uh,
devotion to the principles of Liberty
Fraternity inequality was I trying to plan
these 220,000 articles and books
that will be written about him until,
uh,
1980.
Uh,
and this was a sheer invention of the
past because the record is quite clear in
his writings and what he
said that he can sort of,
so of course it can,
but yet,
uh,
the French ness of the revolution
overwhelmed that in him.
And in the end he remained a Frenchman,
like very many people,
uh,
with a,
a strong accent.
Uh,
and in his case that of Corsica.
Now,
there were some other obvious
things that of course,
it can about him,
uh,
that remained.
And again,
this is part of the
stereotype every when France,
like other countries,
one has stereotypes about
different regions in France.
People think,
for example,
that th those from the
center of France from Vannia,
uh,
are cheap.
Got Down in France that they're cheap.
Uh,
or that people in Maasais exaggerate.
If you say something in French,
uh,
you're from,
I say,
aren't you?
After they just said that they caught out,
you know,
a thousand pound perch
or something like that,
or,
uh,
you know,
their mousay had just scored
the goal of the century.
I mean,
there's a tendency and people
are Maasais to exaggerate.
And these sort of,
these sort of stare at regional
stereotypes are part of a,
of,
of any of any country.
So one of the stereotypes.
So there's something to do this,
uh,
truth with this is the
idea of family loyalty.
I mean,
most people are loyal to the families,
but Napoleon took the kind of clan,
uh,
identity,
a bit,
uh,
a bit strong.
And of course,
what he does is he purchased his,
uh,
various brothers on the Thrones of,
of almost everywhere,
uh,
this kind of family loyalty.
But it's not just people from Corsica who
might given that situation do the same
thing,
but also there's the settling of scores.
Uh,
and Napoleon,
uh,
you know,
I'll talk about this in a while.
If you do believe that the period is,
we can see the origins of total war there.
I'm a little skeptical about this.
Nonetheless,
when people turned against Napoleon,
uh,
or against the French armies,
his reaction was,
we will,
we're going to pay him back and we're
going to get them not with flashing
knives,
but with executions,
uh,
burning of villages in Palestine and
more about this later in the south of
Italy.
And then the two holes in the,
in the mountains of Austria.
And whether,
whether vengeance is more of a
course that can thing than a,
you know,
a shop in Waf thing or a Leo ne thing,
or Brett tall thing,
or a north German thing or
Polish thing or whatever,
one can't say,
but yet,
I know lots of the,
of the thinking about Napoleon's looks
for things that remained course a can of
course that can,
um,
uh,
of course it can,
about him now.
Um,
and I,
having said all of that,
what should we do?
Let's,
yeah,
let's now turn to this
question of whether,
uh,
we think,
and it's just a rhetorical question,
whether a,
my different David Bell is right,
that,
uh,
that you can see the origins
of total war in this period.
That one thing I'm a little skeptical
about is that if you compare this to the
30 years' war,
uh,
and you saw those
ghoulish a illustrations,
uh,
before of different ways you could perish
at the hands of enemies determined for
no particular reason in many
cases is simply destroy you.
Uh,
it,
it's,
it's not clear whether that,
the revolutionary period and the,
uh,
and,
the Napoleonic wars,
uh,
really it was the first,
um,
but yet if we think allow,
and that's what I'm doing.
Uh,
if we see the origins of
total war in world war one,
where the mobilization of state resources
as much as possible to the war and,
and again,
in World War Two,
uh,
and,
particularly in world war two,
the breaking down of,
of,
uh,
the differentiation between
civilians and non civilians.
That happens a little bit
in 1914 but not that much.
It happens in,
in the massacre that Turkish massacres
of the Armenians in 1895 and 1915 that
happens too.
Uh,
but,
um,
it is possible to argue that the
revolutionary and particularly in the
pollyannic period,
uh,
from that point of view,
the mobilization of,
of,
you know,
burning down or melting church bells and,
and,
you know,
transforming,
uh,
you know,
almost every available industrial
site into war production and,
and turning down all these
cannonballs and all these,
all these rifles,
uh,
and all these swords
and all these band nets,
uh,
with the,
the total resources of the state,
um,
directed toward war.
That,
I mean,
there,
there is a a point there.
So there's really two
sides of that argument.
Uh,
that that's one,
the mobilization of resources,
the Levee en masse,
the,
uh,
mass military conscription,
that all citizens,
the male citizens are going to be part of,
uh,
of the,
are going to be in the army.
Uh,
this starts with the French
revolution after all voted me was the,
the battle.
And you're the windmill
near shuttle on some fine.
Yeah.
And the east of France,
uh,
the song culottes going to a war was,
was,
uh,
you know,
was the Levee en masse.
We're ordinary people,
uh,
are,
are full of enthusiasm and singing.
Patriotic songs are heading off to,
uh,
to,
um,
uh,
to fight the enemy.
But the other side of this
total war story is of course,
uh,
um,
you know,
what happens to this
feeling in population and,
and,
uh,
Napoleon once said,
in one of his rare moments of,
of a real introspection,
I,
that he didn't give a damn if,
if a,
a million men are a million
people died because of them.
he believed every part of his,
you know,
a great failing is great.
There's a great weakness and,
and,
and the,
the suffering of humanity
because of it was his identity.
The,
his sense that no matter what he did,
there was the right thing to do.
He has is the sort of hallucination
moment in about 1896 after one of his
battles.
I think it's our call where,
where he sees after himself,
he sees themselves transported
in the air and the,
and that the whole world seemed to be
like you're taking off on an airplane.
Uh,
the whole world is beneath him.
And at that point,
he has this sort of sense that,
that what he would will as a human being
would inevitably because become reality
because he willed it.
And the other half of the sort
of total war aspect is that,
you know,
to be sure and not only,
uh,
did something like one of every French
males born who would have been eligible
for military Terry Service die during
the revolution and Napoleonic wars.
Uh,
but the,
the sort of meaning out of,
of,
of a brutal vengeance more than just
in a course that consents to people who
crossed his will,
does anticipate in some ways,
if you will.
And I'm not even sure
you know how much I shop.
I leave that,
believe this,
but,
uh,
the 20th century,
um,
because on one hand is as the difference
between soldiers and civilians are,
uh,
are being eliminated,
with the sort of,
uh,
the end of the really just professional
army of the 18th century as hospital get
a lot of people killed
in the 18th century to,
uh,
and that those professional,
army wars and,
and all that business,
uh,
but,
but victims to,
uh,
are not just military people.
And of course,
the worst atrocities
committed by French troops,
uh,
were,
in this sort of madcap Egyptian,
uh,
Middle Eastern,
adventure when he goes off
with a boat packed with,
with scientists as well as munitions and,
and lots to eat.
And it goes off to Egypt.
And imagine the conquering India.
I mean,
and he had an idea how far India was away.
And of course,
when people don't put up with this,
then he massacres them in Palestine.
They just,
they raised villages.
And that's the end of that.
And as I said before,
the examples before
would be a in Calabria,
in the south of,
of,
uh,
um,
of Italy when there,
when there is persistent,
so rebellions resistance
to French rule and why not?
Uh,
then they just start massacring people.
and of course the famous
case of Spain where you have,
uh,
that are,
you know,
forever on these magnificent
canvases of Goya,
uh,
that were French troops are
shooting down Spanish peasants,
uh,
who are resisting in the peninsular war.
You know,
these two.
But I guess by more modern definitions,
uh,
not contemporary ones
necessarily from that period,
but we would be classified as,
as massacres.
So it's possible this isn't
too far fetched to imagine,
uh,
the,
the sort of total war is
as being part of that,
of that experience.
And W from seventh,
from,
whoa,
really from 1792,
two,
18,
15,
the experience of ordinary people,
uh,
in much of Europe was war.
Uh,
so,
uh,
you know,
there is,
uh,
you know,
there,
there is that too,
and you know,
in a,
in Napoleon's reaction to all of that,
uh,
was,
I mean,
as you're [inaudible],
he,
he didn't really care.
And after every big defeat,
uh,
the next step was to
plant plan the next war.
And the most famous
example of course is when,
uh,
you've got hundreds of
thousands of people that are,
you know,
that are picked off by Russian partisans.
And why not,
uh,
or freeze to death in the Russian winter.
I,
when Napoleon with this as sort of a
ragtag band of survivors when they,
uh,
you know,
when they get back to France,
uh,
one can see why that French expression
to lie like a military bulletin comes
into existence because
the military Woolton that,
that people,
that church people had to read
that priest had to read in a,
at mass said that,
uh,
the emperor's health
and never been better.
And of course that was true enough.
Uh,
and he immediately begins to start,
uh,
planning,
another war.
And of course,
when he,
uh,
when you know caustics,
are,
are camped on [inaudible] and indeed start
the first Russian restaurant in Paris
in 1814 and he's packed off to,
to the island of Elba,
uh,
not too far from the Italian coast,
and he makes his hundred days
escape and lands at Frazier in the,
in the south of France.
Uh,
and Marshall Ne a famously throws himself
into his arms after having been sent
to arrest him.
Uh,
Napoleon is immediately
planning the next war.
Uh,
and then that ends,
uh,
and I'll happily for the
rest of Europe at Waterloo,
uh,
when Napoleon,
typically does not designate or delegate
enough authority and Marshall Gushi
does not come to to rescue him and
he's rounded up and sent so far away.
It's a little,
it's a little different difficulty to
plan the next year of Korean War if the
closest port is some 600
miles away and is in PR who,
or someplace like that.
So,
um,
I,
I mean,
I made this part of what I'm saying
today and it's kind of a rhetorical way.
I'm posing a question,
you know,
cause I don't really have
a good answer to that.
But if you,
if you,
I don't believe that history
runs on railroad tracks,
and all you need is the timetable
to see when modern times show up.
But if you look at the horrors
of the 20th century and you know,
the,
uh,
the butchery of civilians,
well,
1895 they Armenian massacre
or the butchery of civilians
after the Paris commune
of 1871,
it's not too hard to see all of this.
We're not yet talking
about about the Holocaust.
We're not talking about World War Two,
uh,
but yet some of that,
some of that was out there and,
uh,
that,
you know,
I,
again,
one more point to is,
is that I ran,
I'm not obviously not defending
the know French soldiers,
uh,
in the,
it's very unusual for me not to
be defending lafond everything,
all things French,
but,
but nonetheless,
uh,
you know,
one of the cases that you might say
total war comes before Napoleon,
and this of course,
is the Von Day,
which I alluded to the other day.
Uh,
the civil war in the West,
because there you had cases of
them simply razing villages and,
and lining people up against the wall and,
and,
and gunning down priests and drowning
nuns and this sort of extremely antiques,
uh,
a social antisocial behavior.
Uh,
but one of the things that,
uh,
about,
you know,
these civil wars and the case was what
was the true in Spain is that from point
of view of soldiers,
anybody who was a PR in a guerrilla war,
anyone was,
uh,
a potential,
assailant.
Uh,
and so again,
and this is not excusing
what French troops did,
uh,
in the von day,
but two made it a big political issue,
which people did in 1989,
the 200th anniversary of the French
revolution and say as the first genocide,
which is what the far right was saying,
a traditional far right,
not Le Pen and [inaudible].
And those folks who would be happy to,
you know,
massacre,
uh,
almost anybody who they
didn't view is French,
but,
uh,
I mean it is,
sure is his sheer nonsense.
It's a,
it's simply not the case.
So,
I mean,
there are some,
there are some contexts that
that should be provided,
uh,
in,
in thinking about that.
But it's an interesting theme
and it's worth discussing.
And when you're,
when you're doing,
uh,
this reading,
which I hope you will do,
um,
that,
uh,
that's not a bad idea to think about.
Okay.
Um,
let me just make a,
you know,
a few points.
We have about 10 minutes left,
and this is just to amplify what,
uh,
what you're reading about.
I mean,
because,
um,
you know,
anyone who's ever had to
wait in line at a prefecture,
uh,
in France for a driver's license,
or in our case,
our are a French identity cards,
uh,
or,
almost anything else.
Uh,
we'll be cursing Napoleon,
uh,
for having,
maintain this sort of centralization
that emerged out of absolutism,
uh,
and was honed,
in defense of the republic
by folks like the,
of public safety.
Uh,
but we're Napoleon,
uh,
founded,
you know,
a rational,
enlightened way on honor gimme in quotes,
enlightened way out of the,
out of the enlightenment
way of organizing a state.
Um,
and,
and certainly,
uh,
Napoleon,
who,
you know,
whether he snatched the crown out of the
Pope's hand and crowned himself or let
the pope crown him,
uh,
is not the issue.
I mean,
Napoleon could have pretty
much done whatever he wanted.
Uh,
but in fact,
what he does is he maintains,
uh,
they did the departments
that each pop come,
all,
uh,
and,
um,
the department is created in 1790.
They send a prefect,
uh,
who is,
you know,
like the intendant,
but w w,
uh,
even more centralized,
the all chrome dome to
each day pop them all,
uh,
in 1800.
And they keep the same kind of
top down centralized organization.
Uh,
you know,
if somebody wants to,
the gall was divided up into three parts.
One,
thinking about France,
uh,
at the time of Napoleon or
anytime afterward could say,
take the same thing that,
that,
that France was divided up into,
uh,
the Ministry of the interior
of the Ministry of Justice
and the Ministry of war.
Uh,
and he,
he Napoleon who ruthlessly,
uh,
censored newspapers and they're
forced them out of business.
And made the costs of their continuation.
So extremely difficult.
Uh,
wow.
Organizing or orchestrating
the cult of Napoleon,
whether it be through
sort of paid artists,
some of them,
you know,
extremely great artist,
uh,
or,
lesser versions.
Uh,
uh,
he,
he maintains the kind
of centralization that,
that,
that became important in,
in,
uh,
in France and in places where we're,
we're,
uh,
the,
the waves of French troops
at Liberty Fraternity,
equality and all of that in quotes,
uh,
and ended up,
I mean,
that,
that may maintains,
um,
is maintained.
Um,
he,
he liked to think that
the Napoleonic code,
uh,
was,
um,
was his greater,
uh,
greatest contribution.
He wanted him to be the,
the modern Justinian.
And in fact,
he does oversee lots of the beatings of,
of,
of lawyers and,
and,
you know,
jurists and specialists.
And,
you know,
I mean,
it's classic looking back from our view.
it's patently ridiculous
that there were many,
many more times articles
dealing with the sale of cattle.
Then there were a,
of the rights of women.
Now,
this isn't too surprising because,
uh,
Napoleon,
as many dictators are including much
more egregious ones that Mussolini and
Hitler in the,
in the,
in the 20th century,
uh,
viewed women as nothing more than
machines for producing babies.
And he said this,
he said this exactly like that.
Um,
and so,
uh,
but,
but yet,
yet,
and,
and I mean,
that's a big yet,
uh,
the Napoleon on a code survives and,
and remains in many cases the
basis for the French legal system.
Uh,
and so again,
this is an enlightenment,
a enterprise in many ways gone,
right?
Uh,
and it is there,
um,
uh,
among the other side of contributions,
I mean,
we don't have really time to talk about,
and it's obvious about this sort
of nationalism and that that one's,
one's value comes from service to the
state as opposed from royal blood.
Uh,
though he creates this noon ability,
uh,
based upon service to the state.
And the service of the state was a,
was a bubble,
uh,
through the army.
So a lot of these people who
become marshals and all of this,
if they were lucky enough to
survive all these ridiculous wars,
uh,
our,
our military types.
Uh,
but,
um,
I,
he,
you know,
the deployment of code and,
and,
and this new sort of service,
uh,
a nobility are important things.
The [inaudible] he does,
uh,
a very important thing.
And He,
and he makes peace with,
uh,
with,
with the Catholic Church.
Uh,
and,
um,
he realized that,
that,
that as long as you had this potential
contrast between during priests and non
during priests,
uh,
and that I,
you would still have lots of,
of,
of Middleton Catholics who wanted some
sort of royalist a restoration and indeed
him and the king was dead.
Uh,
and his son had died also in prison,
uh,
in Paris.
But you've still got,
uh,
you know,
still got the king's brother out there.
And,
uh,
so it's a very,
very shrewd move.
Of course,
he uses the church for his
own propaganda devices.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
the tr church,
it continues to tradition of the,
really the civil constitution
of the French clergy,
uh,
the relationship between the Church and,
and,
uh,
and the regime and the planet regime.
But this is an important,
very important,
clever,
a step,
uh,
that,
that basically ends the,
the,
the turmoil,
uh,
within,
um,
within France at least in and add that
to the extent and the old revolutionary
calendar of Jeremy Nolen
voluntold this and,
and,
uh,
Thermador he,
I mean,
that all disappears and is
replaced by the basic calendar.
Uh,
you know,
people,
uh,
still in,
you know,
in 1796 and 95,
uh,
in rural France,
are not thinking of,
you know,
10 day units called Decky d,
uh,
something like that.
They're,
they're thinking of
weeks and they still are,
uh,
are,
are having math said secretly,
which was the case in our village.
Uh,
uh,
even in 1794,
until they finally,
the priest,
uh,
has to,
it has to go away.
Uh,
but,
but the comb corp did this,
this creation of,
of,
um,
maybe this piece with,
uh,
with the churches is obviously
very important thing.
Um,
and so is it is really the
establishment of the basis of,
of the French educational system
that's remain for better or for worse,
the,
uh,
the same until today.
I'm a big believer in the,
uh,
in the French educational system.
My kids were in the front schools for,
for three or four years,
uh,
and,
there's no higher sort of,
uh,
a good result of,
of humanity's collective,
a good deeds than a,
than a French kindergarten or first or
second grade and begins to fall apart.
By the time you get to least say a,
He created the least day,
the high schools.
And then of course,
the university system,
uh,
is now in total chaos and,
and,
uh,
Sarcozi.
We'll probably make it even worse if he
gets this way about creating this sort
of American like hierarchy of institutions
and will be really be at the expense
of kind of,
uh,
of,
of the,
not the lower level,
but the more modest,
uh,
universities in [inaudible]
in the French system,
but be that as it may,
Napoleon and may or may
not be true that he wants,
that he could look at his watch and see
what everybody is studying at any given
moment.
Uh,
and there are lots of problems with,
with a French,
uh,
a system,
but,
but the division of France into academy,
again,
this has nothing to do with the
academies have been talking about before,
but into,
as a geographic way of organizing all
education from the universities down to,
uh,
down to kindergarten or
even to crash even to,
to nursery schools,
uh,
organized by region.
Uh,
it has lasted through all this time.
I mean,
that really is an
extraordinary accomplishment.
And Academy,
for example,
now would be the academy of
the most or the Academy of,
of Gun Oberlin.
And,
and it would,
uh,
or the Academy of Maasais
or the Khan Academy of,
of straws bull.
And it covers two or three,
three or four,
depending on the region,
uh,
departments.
And,
uh,
you know,
it's almost impossible to
get a school teacher fired,
by the way.
I mean,
that's another thing is,
is that,
I mean,
I shouldn't go into be very indiscreet
to go about this into this too much,
but,
you know,
if you're trying to get a school
teacher in a village fired,
I mean,
you can't,
uh,
you know,
it has to go through the,
the head of the whole academy
who is called the rector,
the rector or the rec placement.
I'm not like Theresa Missoula director.
Uh,
uh,
it's,
it's very impossible.
But there are problems with that.
But nonetheless,
the reason that,
that,
and here I tell them that this is
a very pro French thing to say,
but the reason that friend's children
as finished children and his children,
almost a,
in most of European countries,
tested a very much higher level
than those in the United States.
At any level,
you can imagine.
Uh,
it's because,
uh,
of they have centralized education system,
which does not believe
that you should have,
you know,
wealthy communes,
a wealthy parts of France
having all of the advantages.
And then schools that have very low,
uh,
limited financial resources have a,
have not the same,
uh,
the same possibilities,
for exceptional advancement.
And this,
I mean,
France has the goal,
they call it.
I mean,
uh,
the,
the big time,
uh,
big,
a high powered,
uh,
elite schools,
elite universities,
they've got their,
their equivalents of,
of the fancy places of
which you're all in,
in one now.
Uh,
but,
but nonetheless,
uh,
Napoleon does create a
system which is long lasting,
uh,
and which,
allowed over time,
uh,
the educational structure of,
of France to,
to advanced and very,
very meaningful ways,
uh,
in the whole course of the period.
So no matter what you think
about the fact that he,
in,
in the end,
he was a megalomaniac and lots of
people get killed because of them.
Uh,
there's no doubt about that,
but,
but the wave of the French revolution
and the deploy manic period,
uh,
has long lasting results,
almost everywhere.
To take an example of
unification of Italy,
Italy will become unified in the 1860s,
uh,
in early 1870s unified in quotes,
a metro nick said it was
a geographic expression,
a only,
and to an extent,
he may have been,
uh,
correct.
The unification comes through Piedmont,
Piedmont,
Sardinia,
which was the most prosperous
part of Italy's and the north,
uh,
and,
they had the benefits of
this French bureaucracy of
this administration that was
centralized,
uh,
that allow them to be
more prosperous than,
than other parts of Italy.
And it contributes to that.
They had other advantages,
uh,
to and,
and,
uh,
so the Napoleonic wave did
make a difference though.
It's hard to,
when you go to Paris and
if you go to the Louvre,
uh,
it's hard to not think of the fact that
the many of the treasures that are there
were simply alluded,
uh,
from,
from Italy.
Uh,
I loaded a,
a not in a trains as,
as Gooding,
uh,
and gribbles and those folks looted
art treasures during World War II.
Uh,
but put very carefully packed on,
on a military wagons
and returned to Paris.
So we can debate about Napoleon,
uh,
and all of that.
My view was already probably fairly clear.
Uh,
but one has to admit that,
that,
that besides just the romance of his life
and a career open to talent and all of
that,
uh,
that he made a huge difference and
thus was worth spending some time on.
Have a good weekend.
I'm going to Saint Louis.